Hi. I'm Brian Naughton. I'm Founding
Scientist at 23andMe. I'm from Dublin, Ireland.
>> So after dropping the DNA sample in the mail,
we don't see anything until we get to our results.
what happens to that sample once we drop it in
the mail? Where does it go? Where does it end up
>> So your sample actually gets shipped to our lab
in Los Angeles where it gets processed. there are four major
components to that, it starts with
DNA extraction, then amplification of the DNA,
then hybridization and finally, analysis of the data to make sure it's good.
>> Okay, great. About how long does that
process take for, to do all those steps?
>> So if you take all of the steps and you
did end to end it would probably take three days or so.
>> Mm-hm.
>> a lot of the process is just waiting for the equipment to become
available because of volume.
>> I see. What of all those sort of four processes,
which of those is the most time intensive of all of them?
>> The most time intensive is the hybridization step, which happens
overnight, amplification also happens over night though. So there are two
major parts where we have to leave the DNA for a
while and come back to it, so it has time to
>> about what
what I mean, I'm curious what, what's the
most expensive part of the of the process?
>> So the, the chip and the reagents are really the expensive part of
the process. When you buy the chip you also get the reagents those are
like the chemicals that you need to run the chip. the other expensive components
are probably labor, obviously because we actually
need to hire what's called high complexity
staff to run our process.
[UNKNOWN]
staff and then the, the rest is actually fairly inexpensive.
>> What are the are there
any international restrictions? Like obviously I'm guessing
if the lab time only takes you, like you said, three days, but
you know longer if you're processing multiple samples you know does it take
a lot longer for any international people who want to have this service done?
>> So the lab process doesn't take
longer obviously the shipping is an issue and
shipping can be expensive if you're coming
from Asia to California. that's part of
the reason why we want to add another lab actually it's to help with that.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> There are also issues with exporting DNA from certain
countries so China and India specifically have laws around what DNA
you are allowed to export out of that country. So
that, that plus other regulations regarding biological specimens mean that it's
actually quite difficult to add another country to our list of countries.